avec les équipes on a préparé un
parcours de cactus c'est très simple
regardez ils sont là bas est ce qu'on
peut avoir un plot sur les équipes là
bas regardez sur tous avec des ballons
c'est très simple ils vont devoir faire
un parcours avec des ballons ils vont
devoir mettre trente secondes pour faire
le parcours sans s'en péter un ballon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et la famille ou vtt attendu mon option
mais vite à 30 secondes de temps les
populations
combien
nasser privé pour kelly merci echems ont
été dans les bulles deux là pour donner
de réponse il faut fermer le label
alors on nous étions sur gad elmaleh qui
a fait une révélation et gad elmaleh
j'ai refusé dans ces questions peuvent
animer une émission aux états unis où je
vais remplir le stade de france avec les
ex de castries
allez y vite wave race pour un truc
d'oisien à lévis vas-y mamie pousse même
souffle pouce aux balais ou alors il
faut qu'elle soit plus grosse attention
qui me regardent encore belge de la part
de bad run est là ça va c'est pas ton
émission est vite vite vite vite il faut
pas que tu prêtes à ballon attention
attention
ouais ouais
oui oui à les badges d'accès basées
bathie seras tu là dessus basi maxime
robin et maxime chère aux finances a
terminé
la barre l'avocat de laetitia l'idée sur
ses news lowrie david ont tout manigancé
la bataille judiciaire va durer dix ans
ou mamie rock étaient en maternelle avec
isabelle morini bosc
alors qu'a déclaré alors qu'il veut
faire la bulle qui veut faire la bulle
qui veut faire la bulle maximale
si tu fais ah oui quand-même 1.5 est pas
bien non c'est pas parfait
benjamin non non alinghi java s'adorent
voilà c'est ça la foutrait ex femme me
dit si les salles oui alors l'oreille
david en ont tout bon exemple
bravo bonhomme mamani matthieu delormeau
a tenté par baby
beat et fais attention tu vas te baisser
quelque chose
pas mal pas mal ait ans avec le cactus
quand on est sain déjà atteint il a
perdu un ballon mais ne l'a pas il n'a
pas prêté attention
il n'a pas commis le ballon vas-y vas-y
ça te rappelle que j'ai fait l'armée
arrêts parmi ces terminaux dont matthieu
delormeau c'est terminé oui oui c'est
terminé je vais demander à gaston
lagaffe il pas d gastaud m'a dit
attention c'est gaston lagaffe s'est
placé gaston j'ai perdu c'est perdu tu
vas jouer d'accord tu vas jouer pour
gagner un très très beau cadeau d'accord
mon florian isabelle morini-bosc arrive
à faire tout le parcours en gardant un
ballon encore gonfler le miracle d'un
miracle tu gagnes un énorme cadeau
floflo d'accord mon clown attention
c'est parti
vaduz avec ta tout le temps que tu veux
un même toutes les missions
et sans tu gardes le moins abalo
normalement c'est non mais non c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave et c'est dans
l'autre sens
mais non mais c'est pas que ça de slalom
mathieu massy vas-y allez vas-y vas-y
vas-y zabel mort dès la q1 mais ce toit
besco alsa allez vas-y usa mais non mais
non à t'inquiéter vraiment vécu ouais
c'est bien fait attention quand même va
pas de blessé oui il y aurait il reste
encore très attention
c'est gagné